it's incredible it's okay
just the way he does it yeah he brings
his voice down he goes it's incredible i
love your tone you're like the opposite
of you you've got this anger you have
this i hate that about myself i'm trying
to get rid of it but really bold you're
that's got
you want to get rid of that and i'm like
the fat guy who's going to get skinny
and then i don't work anymore
you're really trying are you an angry
guy
uh i have anger issues i'm i don't walk
around like that like where i am right
now this is how i i walk around but the
thing about it is is i can ramp up i can
go from this
to through the ceiling not as much
anymore because uh you know i've gotten
into therapy i took mushrooms
you know
through your therapist was that
recommended
have you have you taken a mushroom no
they do that they do that now they do
micro dosing for mushrooms for different
that's my kid yeah
let's see over the shoulder yes
no but that's a real thing that they do
now for therapy yeah i saw this thing um
uh a buddy of mine
showed me
had me watch it after i took it
after i took him it was uh i forget what
the hell was called but it was like over
in israel they use it for uh ptsd and
they had like three people one person um
uh you know there was a terrorist attack
and they blew up a bus and came walking
up and just saw the carnage so somebody
else got molested somebody else got
kidnapped this woman so they all like
were they just showed this whole thing
where they were taking it it was sort of
a guided thing so you weren't just like
freaking out and they i don't know they
they had they would they were claiming
they took mushrooms and then showed
these images to people who are on
mushrooms no no no no these people had
gone through this oh so to to relieve
them of their of their children yes and
they allegedly had they were claiming
they had like an 80 percent success rate
at treating ptsd so
you know i i don't know i don't know
anything about it i know i just what did
it do for you
uh it woke me up i feel like i got a
piece of [ __ ] lint or something in my
mouth that's something i saw fly off of
blue okay
off of lou's lion's mane
he's loving your hair oh i come on dude
you got the hassle off going off there
well you know uh uh
my mother
always said that my hair is growing
because i watch it too often she thought
water in the hair made like plants yeah
she because that's what she understood i
want to eat whatever water you have i
need it um
all right no i i had like you know i was
giggling and you know [ __ ] looked like
it was breathing that shouldn't be
breathing you know what i mean and then
uh all of a sudden i just felt like this
this profound sense of loneliness and
not feeling loved and that's what i
ended up having to figure out like what
is this what is this thing so i didn't
have a good trip but my buddy said dude
you don't get the trip you want you get
the trip you need
and it was kind of like claire's day
that okay i need to figure out why i
feel like this and i and i i just
i i immediately knew who i was lou
please let me finish this this is an
amazing part of the story
please don't slow it down with your
sunday newspaper story again
i ended up uh i knew exactly who i was
after it i knew every every good thing
every bad thing i finally understood who
i was is that good and it is good
because they say ignorance is bliss and
that sounds like you're just too aware
no it was great it was blessed for 10
days and then after 10 days the reality
of everything that happened to you still
happened so then you got to kind of work
your way through that but i it sounds
you know your description sounds
horrible to be honest with you like i
haven't you know how i came in here i
complimented your jacket you know i
bowed down to the king and then you know
i'm trying to you know tell your story
here and you're just like i i wasn't i
yeah but i'm afraid to and and people
have suggested micro dosing and that's
why i'm asking i know this about you too
because i know you're a big proponent of
therapy and you go to therapy but you
are not a fan about talking when it
comes to talking about your issues
because you don't want to think about it
right like you'd rather have it be
ignorance's bliss kind of thing no i'm
no i know you're right i can tell by the
look on his face it is true
my big thing is distraction rather than
thinking about the things right but what
i'm saying is
if you can distract away from that yes
okay no but i'm talking about the what
your your description
of i took this microdose it's supposed
to open you up and you're supposed to no
it wasn't micro micro dose i think
people use that to stave off like
depression or something i'm i don't know
what the hell they take it for i'm just
i'm i took it one time and i just want
to just get into tripping which i did i
was full-on trip i wasn't seeing like
dragons and [ __ ] no you were seeing [ __ ]
breathing and you realize that nobody
loves you that's what you told me no i
realized that if that that you felt
unloved it wasn't even felt it just was
i can't even expect
about the story i'm talking this is
really interesting i'm i'm trying to
break down why you think this is an
advantage to because
the next day i felt clear the next day
clear that nobody loves you no it's just
that that this is
i i was basically how i felt growing up
and what i carried with me and then i
realized
i just realized everything that i was
doing how much i was stuff i was pushing
away how you know all the bits i've done
about women and all of this [ __ ] like i
understood why i was i went at it the
way i went at it i understood my issues
i don't want to get in all of it why is
that important though why is it
important to understand where your
comedy is coming from when it's
hilarious to begin with why i wasn't
talking about comedy i'm just talking
about who i am okay but why i guess the
question kind of because then if you
find out who you are and why and then
like especially me if you have like a
temper that's hard for people around you
do you not find that your temper is your
good is a good fuel for your comedy
no it on on stage
on stage so don't you find that stage
listen if you walked around with the big
glove on your head around your house i
mean how long would be there before like
dead
can you just be dad
you know what i mean
it would be it's like you have to like
uh you know i thought
through the way i grew up that if i
wasn't yelling at people then i i wasn't
as bad as some of the [ __ ] i saw growing
up but i just didn't grow up in a rough
uh upbringing i grew up in a rough time
like everybody just in general like it
was uh you know there was no therapy i
think there was like one book
how to win friends how to win friends
and influence people i think was the
only thing there was no dr phil there
was no nothing so you had all these men
who were supposed to be like the john
wayne prototype and they were just white
knuckling their way through stuff so
there was uh everything from just silent
rage to rage rage
and then all of us and then flipping on
a dime and be like hey how was school
you know after stuff like that happened
so
i just from you know are you close with
your family now yeah everything's cool
everything's cool it's just like uh
you know um
you know your job when you become a
parent is to try to make it a little
better break the cycle
what keep what worked
you know and then you know do you have
siblings yeah i don't know anything
about you you have to you have siblings
what do you have brothers yeah i don't
know i don't try to put too much of that
out there because there's too many
weirdos out there but yeah i was not an
only child but
[Music]
bye